Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome to Terror Lab.
[Boop]
Flashbang ready.
[SHWOP]
Good god, man! What did I do?
'Time to recover memory'?
[whimpering] I don't-
AHH! WHAT THE FUCK!
[Garbled monster noises] HI!
WELCOME TO THE PARTY, BRO!
YOU'RE LATE! WHERE'S THE, CHICKS, MAN?
[Unfitting cheerful music plays]
[Drum sounds]
[Mutual confusion]
[Blinks]
... I'm gonna call you Chad.
[BOOP]
And I don't wanna talk about holes when I'm...
around you, Chad.
You know, tho- it was just an experimental time in college, Chad!
We were just having a bromance and you- you made it all weird, CHAD!
You make me feel things that I don't wanna FEEL!
You make me think about times that I don't wanna think about anymore...
All of our BRO moments!
Our BROments!
WE HAD A GREAT TIME BRO-ING OUT IN THE-
br-b-
BROODS!
THAT'S 'WOODS' IN BROSPEAK!
[BOOP]
We used to have good times back in our early party days.
And I know!
I know Stacy got in between both of us!
Literally AND figuratively!
[BOOP]
Hey Chad, you got a little closer than I thought!
Just like back in college!
WHY CAN'T I QUIT YOU!?
*sob* Why can't I quit you, Cha-
I thought this was a door, I thought I was making a dramatic exit there.
HABPTH!
[First video] Again, that does not help anybody, it just blinds me.
I'm flash-banging myself.
[Second video]
He'll never see me coming!
AHHH! I had you!
Don't swath away!
[
*Really cool beats!*